si les écologistes se présente
aujourd'hui aux élections
présidentielles c'est au nom d'un projet
qui veut répondre à l'ensemble des
problèmes que se posent les français les
problèmes de la vie quotidienne les
problèmes de la vie économique les
problèmes de la vie internationale
notre projet nous le résumons en cinq
grandes priorités
première priorité protéger la vie la vie
la santé et la nature
deuxième priorité briser la solitude de
la solitude dans les zones rurales et la
solitude dans les grandes villes où
chacun se sent comme un numéro anonymes
qui ne parle plus à ses voisins
troisième priorité domestique et
l'économie domestique à l'économie ça
veut dire consommer mieux et ne pas
toujours produire plus et puis partager
le travail pour résoudre la question du
chômage
quatrième grande priorité développer la
solidarité mondiale pour venir en aide à
toutes les personnes qui sont très
nombreuses dans le monde qui souffrent
de la faim enfin cinquième priorité
créer une véritable démocratie du
quotidien où le citoyen chaque citoyen
peut intervenir sur les questions qui le
concerne
aujourd'hui nous avons choisi de vous
parler de la vie de la protection de la
vie qui demeure pour nous autres
écologistes un point absolument
essentiel et quand on nous dit mais
c'est pas très important tout ça
nous répondons enfin qu'est ce qu'il ya
de plus important que la protection de
la vie et pour en parler
j'ai invité deux personnes une personne
qui est connu sur le plan mondial
une personne qui nous a toujours aidés
j'ai nommé le commandant cousteau le
commandant cousteau qui préside le
comité de soutien à la candidature
écologiste
et puis le journaliste une journaliste
qui vit ici à titre de journaliste
indépendante florence schaal pour nous
aider à conduire le débat concerne la
première question sera très simple il me
semble que la bataille de la pollution
est presque gagné en tout cas tous les
partis politiques l'inscrivent à leur
programme alors pourquoi encore une
candidature écologiste qui parle de la
nature parce que la nature ce n'est pas
uniquement les questions de pollution
quand vous me dites que nous avons gagné
la bataille de la pollution je dirais
dans l'esprit des français oui ils ont
raison c'est vrai mais
et tous les français ont en mémoire ce
qui s'est passé avec la moco cas disent
tous les français peuvent lire quand ils
lisent les journaux que il y à une
pollution très préoccupante de l'eau des
nappes phréatiques c'est à dire que
l'agriculture industrielle
malheureusement laisse des nitrates ce
qu'on appelle des nitrates dans l'eau
tout le monde peut voir également
combien dans ce que nous mangeons
il peut y avoir une pollution par les
pesticides ou souvenez-vous récemment de
la sphère du veau aux hormones vous le
monde sait aussi lorsqu'on habite près
d'une centrale nucléaire ou d'une
installation de ce genre là que
quelquefois on vit comme sur un baril de
poudre mais c'est pas simplement ça il
n'y a pas que les pollutions tout bien
se rendre compte que la nature c'est
presque un espèce de grand tout une
grande famille dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons nous aussi et la question la
plus préoccupante peut-être vraiment
celle qui nous fait le plus peur c'est
la disparition progressive du patrimoine
vivant c'est de voir qu'il y a de plus
en plus d'espèces animales et végétales
qui sont menacées de disparition en
france le ministère de l'environnement a
écrit un jour qu'il y en avait près de
40% c'est énorme
imaginez que vous lisiez un dictionnaire
que vous preniez un stylo que vous
barrier comme ça 40% des mots du
dictionnaire d'un bout d'un certain
temps on s'est peut-être produit qu'il
fait parler la langue tout simplement
c'est aussi une préoccupation du
commandant cousteau puisque vous avez
passé une partie de votre vie à vous
élever contre la destruction des espèces
mais ce que j'en sors c'est en quoi la
destruction des espèces
nous sommes aussi importantes pour la
société bien c'est en effet un mes yeux
la question la plus importante après la
surpopulation
il est certain que nous nous battons non
pas pour survivre car rien de plus
triste que de survivre mais pour vivre
dignement et pour vivre une vie
intéressante
or un premier point qui al'air futile
mais qui ne l'est pas avez vous remarqué
l'émerveillement des enfants devant une
abeille devant une fleur devant un brin
d un brin d'herbe
si vous supprimez tout ça qu'est ce
qu'il aura à voir du béton des
automobiles des avions c'est ce sera si
nice temps pour lui de ne voir que ça or
donc ça c'est un point mais aussi et
surtout la destruction des espèces nous
menacent
car la pyramide de la vie c'est une
pyramide temps nous occupons le sommet
plus cette pyramide est large à la base
plus elle est solide et si on détruit
les espèces à la base les plantes les
insectes les petits animaux qui forment
cette base de la pyramide on se trouve
avec une pyramide très haute où nous
serons au en haut mais très étroite et
que le mot la moindre catastrophe peut
balayer et nous donc c'est une question
fondamentale pour survivre et pour vivre
mieux et vous dénoncez aussi la
surexploitation des ressources
naturelles
et pourtant ces ressources qui sont donc
de l'énergie on a besoin pour notre
société
bien sûr on a besoin de ressources et
nous nous sommes tournés vers les
ressources est plus facile qui sont les
ressources fossiles
les ressources épuisables les
écologistes voudraient qu'on attache
beaucoup plus l'importance aux
ressources inépuisables
c'est à dire ressources qui sont
renouvelés par la nature c'est pour nous
une question fondamentale et tout un tas
de facteurs sont en train de remettre ça
en question
mais le principal facteur c'est la
mauvaise gestion aujourd'hui de cette
question des ressources
les dirigeants du monde entier aussi
bien politique qu'industriel créé
économique pas seulement au sein quant
aux six ans qui viennent aux intérêts
mesquins des nations et non pas à
l'intérêt de la planète en général
alors on parle d'avoir par exemple
l'autonomie énergétique pourquoi pas
l'autonomie du café pourquoi pas
l'autonomie les bananes c'est absurde
on peut aussi bien acheter l'énergie à
soccer nom et leur vendre ce que nous
avons et qui n'ont pas il ya là et là
une espèce d'égoïsme nationale qui
conduit automatiquement à la mauvaise
gestion des ressources un bruit mais moi
je crois que il faut vraiment insisté
aussi sur l'extraordinaire gaspillage de
notre modèle parce que par exemple la
nature ce sont aussi les arbres bien eh
ben
tous les matins je vais regarder mon
courrier j'ai presque pas de lettre qui
me sont adressées à moi mais alors les
prospectus j'en ai surtout d'ailleurs en
ce moment c'est la campagne électorale
nombre d'arbres que chaque candidat
utilise n'est ce pas pour faire toutes
ces affiches qui a partout c'est
invraisemblable
eh bien nous sommes les soldes comme
content que les écologistes là il est
était en accord avec nos idées nous
avons utilisé du papier recyclé et puis
il ya beaucoup d'autres exemples c'est
invraisemblable il n'y a pas longtemps
je n'ai même pas pu rentrer chez moi
parce qu'ils ont remplacé la poignée par
une sonnette électrique alors la soul
est électrique
elles consomment du courant mais moi je
suis très très bien à ouvrir ce n'était
pas un effort extraordinaire
et bien c'est partout pareil de plus en
plus le mode de vie dans lequel nous
nous trouvons c'est un mode de vie qui
jettent qui gaspille qui utilisent à
tort et à travers n'importe quoi je
crois que la première chose est de se
rendre compte premier d'abord que
l'économie de répondre à nos besoins et
nos besoins ils sont pas aussi énorme
qu'il faille y met toute la planète en
perse et besoin vrai et puis la seconde
chose c'est que l'on change de technique
pourquoi ne pas utiliser l'énergie
solaire à la place de nucléaire
l'énergie solaire ne laisse pas de
déchets l'énergie solaire ce n'est pas
d'uranium mais c'est extraordinaire les
techniques modernes le progrès ce qu'on
peut faire avec la mer travaux de boost
aux flammes hier la mère est une source
d'énergie solaire et les puissances
établies nous mentent 1 par exemple
l'énergie solaire qui tombe sur la terre
est équivalente à plus de 160 millions
l'isie nucléaire et la partie qu'on
pourrait utiliser de cette énergie
opposants devraient 40 millions musimu
terre ont même si on en utilise est que
j'ai réduit 5 pour mille en utilisant
par exemple l'énergie thermique des mers
qui est située à la mer le meilleur
consommateurs d'énergie solaire qui
existent par le défaut de l'énergie cias
et qu'il est répartie
la mère de charles de gaulle concentrés
dans des zones privilégiées c'est là
qu'il faut aller l'exploiter le vent
aussi concentré l'énergie solaire dans
des régions précises tout ça pourrait
être organisée de façon à prendre le
relais dans un temps où dans 30 ans d
énergie actuelle mais il n'existe qu'une
certaine somme d'argent disponible pour
les investissements et tout part dans le
nucléaire
par conséquent il ne reste rien pour le
solaire et on nous raconte que le
sollers est pas possible ce sont des
rêves l'écologiste non ce ne sont pas
des ce sont des réalités tangibles et
ben ouais ça il ya une chose qui me
frappe dans ce que vient de dire le
commandant cousteau pourquoi si
l'énergie s'est dit solaire est aussi
productrice énergie pourquoi nos chefs
d'états qui ne sont quand même pas des
gens idiots et qui sont entourés de
chercheurs ont choisi d'investir à fonds
dans l'énergie nucléaire sûre que c'est
une question que nous sommes nous même
posé et bien la réponse hélas ça c'est
triste à dire c'est à cause de la bombe
tout simplement c'est à cause de
l'influencé extraordinaire des
militaires dans cette société
toute l'histoire du nucléaire toute
l'histoire des centrales nucléaires elle
est liée à l'histoire du nucléaire
militaire
les centrales nucléaires que nous
construisons actuellement en france dit
américaine ce sont des sous marins ça
des moteurs de sous marins atomiques
c'est à dire qu'au départ on a construit
six centrales nucléaires comme des
moteurs et puis on s'est aperçu qu'on
pouvait faire de l'électricité avec de
même les centrales nucléaires françaises
sont proposés auparavant ce d'abord des
usines à plutonium désigne plutonium
pourquoi pour créer le matériau dont on
a besoin pour faire la bombe est ce qui
nous inquiète terriblement aujourd'hui
avec ce développement
de plus en plus grand d'une technique
aussi dangereuse c'est c'est tout c'est
retombé militaire c'est que partout dans
le monde
maintenant tout dictateur si vous voulez
veut son nucléaire parce que avec une
centrale même si c'est pour faire
d'électricité il peut aussi s'en servir
pour faire la bombe par conséquent je
crois qu'il faut se rendre compte que le
nucléaire est bien il est pollué par le
militaire et c'est très très grave
oui c'est vrai mais il ya aussi d'autres
d'autres raisons
il ya une autre forme qui m'inquiète
aussi autant c'est le terrorisme
nucléaire car il y à déjà aux etats-unis
une certaine quantité d'uranium enrichi
et de plutonium qui ont disparu sans
laisser de traces et s'attaque non pas
été perdu pour tout le monde et un
navire qui transporte des 400 tonnes de
minerai d'uranium vers l'italie a
disparu et en quand on l'a retrouvé
plusieurs années après il avait changé
de nom
est-ce que j'ai une autre façon et
l'ouragan avait disparu il n'est pas
perdu pour tout le monde et j'ai vu ce
matin d'une nouvelle extravagantes
c'est que le niger a au cours de
plusieurs livraisons déjà livré quatre
cent cinquante tonnes de minerai
d'uranium à la libye bon et la libye
c'est pas tellement pour ses propres
besoins car ses propres besoins sont
contrôlés par les russes qui sont très
pointilleux mais l alibi et en fait
profiter ses amis ses alliés politiques
en particulier au pakistan qui fabrique
une bombe
par conséquent nous on a posé la
question aux dictateurs du niger en lui
disant mais ça vous pose pas le problème
euros alors qu'aurel grinch lundi 6 mais
nous sommes en règle avec notre moral
puisque nous exigeons de nos clients
qu est ce conforme au règlement des
nations unies pour penser comme ça les
arrêtera et
il a même ajouté nous pour nous c'est
sont vitales de vendre d'uranium
et si demain le diable me demander de
lui vendre l'uranium jeanne jugan vrai
et bien ce mot explique toutes les
craintes que nous avons de voir un jour
des terroristes fabriqué comme on sait
le faire aujourd'hui sur une table et
cuisine une bombe avec quelques kilos
d'uranium ou de enrichi ou de plutonium
de même également que le plutonium peut
être utilisé pour imposer les sources
d'eau et en pose nue des vitres de
plusieurs millions d'habitants avec
quelques voix muradian de plutonium
mais là vous parlez du nucléaire et
militaire
et c'est une forme de nucléaire
militaire le terroriste parce que le
jour où une bombe terroriste éclatera
new york par exemple eh bien vous pensez
que sally planchera d'autres réactions
et le là ce sera le feu aux poudres
ensuite nous pousse et toute cette
chaîne depuis la mine jusqu'à jusqu'à la
bombe séoul en passant par les usines
nucléaires qui me terrorise parce que je
pense que les c'est une nouvelle forme
de danger
nous avons été habitués à des dangers
technique les accidents d'aviation les
accidents de voiture etc mais qui ne
concerne que les gens qui sont concernés
tandis que l'univers engage dans le
risque les générations qui ne sont pas
nés et qu'ils ont à subir les fautes que
nous ce que nous commettons c'est à dire
que dans mille ans dans 2000 ans dans
dix mille ans les générations
supporteront les erreurs que nous
aurions fait en lâchant dans
l'atmosphère dans l'eau ou dans la
nature des quantités gigantesques de
plutonium
voilà car le plutonium reste dangereux
pour des dizaines de milliers d'années
donc est-ce que ce que vous ne pensez
pas qu à vous parler du nucléaire
militaire que visiblement pour vous et
aux civils est-ce que vous n'aviez pas
je crois qu'il a déjà des rapports qui
existent qui démontre que même si son
contrat celle controversée qui démontre
que la sécurité nucléaire peut être
assurée alors est-ce qu'on peut pas par
exemple privilégié à nucléaire civil
entièrement contrôlée attendait un vent
avant que van que nous parlions de sa de
ce contrôle il ya une chose quand même
qu'il faut pas oublier c'est que
la l'énergie nucléaire nous est vendu
comme étant plus propre que le charbon
plus propre que le pétrole etc
donc c'est l'énergie écologique par
excellence naturellement on ne parle pas
de la pollution thermique est
gigantesque mais c'est vrai tank a pas
d'accident alors maintenant vous pouvez
poser votre question mais moi ce que je
voulais dire c'est que même s'il n'y a
pas si a pas de faute technique voyez ce
qu'on nous raconte sur l'écologie de du
nucléaire est simplement en oublie cette
pollution thermique qui risquerait
chauffer la planète et faire fondre et
kalmthout la c1 et c'est alors à
d'ailleurs si c'est pour répondre à
cette question la réponse c'est non
les écologistes ne veulent pas de
nucléaire il faut il faut de la fermeté
par conséquent nous nous proposons un
plan de consommation et de production
d'énergie et au terme du prochain
septennat si le président de la
république et et écologistes
il n'y aurait plus de centrales
nucléaires en france il y aurait un
passage progressif à des économies
d'énergie
et puis à des sources d'énergie
renouvelables il faut un jour choisir il
faut un jour décidé mais pas longtemps
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui travaille
dans une centrale nucléaire à gravelines
et il m'a dit ah ça les deux premières
années c'est magnifique c'est nickel une
centrale nucléaire c'est propre ça
brille c'est magnifique
et puis au bout de deux ans c'est pourri
que lui m'a dit c'est lui qui me team
qui met en place à terme c'est pourri
c'est plus droit safu tous les côtés non
sans nucléaire c'est périmé
par conséquent il faut être clair des
écologistes passeront à d'autres sources
d'énergie vous comprenez il faut des
gens parfaits pour que ça fonctionne
ifri technique parfaite ça n'existe
nulle part au monde qui peut me dire
comment on vas y vas tu es paris s'il ya
un accident à nogent sur seine qui peut
me dire comment neva curé nantis ont
construit la centrale du pèlerin c'est
pas possible
moi j'en ai assez de vivre dans un monde
où d'un côté on nous dit que 70% des
cancers sont dus à l'environnement et de
l'autre côté on n'arrête pas de rajouter
des substances cancérigènes à commencer
par le nucléaire
un jour il faut arrêter et s'engager
dans une autre direction vous êtes
d'accord commandant cousteau
oui il faudra à faire ça progressivement
mais je suis parfaitement d'accord
d'autant plus que j'ai été récemment il
ya trois ans visiter un hôpital à
houston consacrée aux enfants qui ne
sont pas guérissable du cancer on
m'avait demandé d'aller les distraire
par ce que ces pauvres gosses étaient
isolés et souffre énormément
la vision est apocalyptique
je suis restée pendant de voir ces
pauvres gosses de 4 ans 5 en hurlant de
douleur avec leur mère pleurant à leurs
cheveux et qu'il n'y avait aucun espoir
rien à faire ce sont des choses qui vous
bouleverse et qu'on n'oublie jamais et
il a raison brice a raison en disant que
toutes les sources de cancer je crois
les 70% des anciens qui sont dues à
l'environnement aujourd'hui c'est bien
oui je crois que j'avais de manière plus
générale c'est vraiment on ne peut pas
le supporter et il faudrait que nous
arrivions à une nouvelle conception de
la santé ce qui me frappe quand on est
quand on écoute les partis ou les
spécialistes que chaque fois qu'on parle
de de santé en réalité les gens parlent
de soins parle de médicaments par
d'hôpitaux la santé ça commence par ne
pas tomber malade temps ne pas avoir
besoin de cela
chaque français dépensent 400000 fondre
sa santé b pourtant les accidents de la
route tue énormément et on a six ont
supprimé deux moitiés l'élection de la
route l'équivalent d'une semaine de
production il faudrait revenir presque à
une situation à la chinoise vous savez
on payait le médecin quand on n'était
pas malade et puis quand on est tombé
malade et bien on ne le paient pas je
crois que en définitive l'écologie c'est
d'abord ça c'est de se rendre compte que
le plus important c'est d'abord la vie
quotidienne la vie quotidienne c'est
d'abord la santé c'est d'abord de
protéger la vie